in my last video I went over 10 ways to
quickly ruin your life and it is by far
the most depressing video I have ever
made in my life and a lot of you who
watched that video said wow I don't
actually need a tutorial for this I see
myself in every single one of those
points and I don't know what to do I've
been depressed for a long time or maybe
I haven't been feeling well for a long
time and this video just sort of reminds
me of what a big piece of [ __ ] I am I
literally read that same comment
verbatim 50 times so I felt obligated to
make this video because I want to take
each point from the last video and flip
it to give you guys some ideas to help
you Rise From the Ashes get out of
whatever depressive rut that you're in
so that you can start feeling better
very quickly step number one is to have
a goal you need to figure out what you
want from your life and a lot of the
time we already kind of know what we
want with our lives but it is sort of
just this vague sentiment we know that
we probably want to have more money or
we want to have a girlfriend or we want
you know to pass school or to feel
better or to have big muscles or cool
hair like we have all these vague
sentiments but we haven't really sat
down and separated the wheat from the
chaff we haven't figured out what things
are actually important to us what things
get us excited to wake up in the morning
and we don't really outline what kind of
person we want to be specifically how do
we ideally want to spend our time how
much time should we spend playing
RuneScape how do we want to feel on a
day-to-day basis what kind of
relationships do we want to have all of
these things are so important to outline
specifically otherwise we don't really
have an aim we have all of these vague
Sentiments of things that we kind of
want and that would be nice but we have
absolutely no specific goals and
absolutely no specific steps to get
there and without that aim we are by
definite Mission aimless so no wonder we
kind of descend into nihilism without a
goal we need goals to strive towards and
it's in that striving that we find
meaning we find that internal
fulfillment that we're usually looking
for when we're spending time on
Instagram and whatnot we're sort of
looking for this feeling of resolution
like you're where you're supposed to be
you find that feeling by being on your
path and you don't know if you're on
your path if you don't have a goal so it
is so important to spend some time sit
down with a pen and paper and figure out
in detail what you want your life to
look like one month from now one year
from now and five years from now step
number two is step out of the cave one
of the easiest ways by far to descend
into despair is to spend all of your
time inside in front of screens getting
sucked into endless algorithms being
force-fed topics that you are growing
tired of and it seems to be the same
things every single day you watch the
same videos and you think the same
thoughts so it's extremely important
that if you don't like that that you
stop spending so much time inside your
house you have to step outside of the
cave let the sunlight and vitamin D hit
your skin go be a person in the world
you know stop spending so much time in
isolation you know that's probably one
of the biggest things that you know the
past couple of years have taught us is
you know spending all of our times in
front of a screen isn't exactly good for
our mental health so emerge from the
cave as much as possible let people know
your name get to know people have people
know you by being a person in the world
we stop being so closed in on ourselves
you know our soul becomes this black
hole that just requires entertainment
and people to validate you and we almost
draw the world in towards ourself rather
than being out there and radiating this
sort of abundant giving nature as
woo-woo as that sounds when we spend so
much time in isolation we get so
self-conscious that every other external
input is sort of like trying to fill
this hole that we create in ourselves
let's stop that get outside of the house
go talk to somebody stop spending all of
your time in your little cave as much as
you are capable go be a person in the
world step number three to dramatically
improve your life is to take risks life
is inherently risky by being alive you
risk Dying by crossing the street you
risk getting hit by a bus there are so
many things that could go wrong and
probably will go wrong in your life and
a lot of these things are completely out
of your control you can't escape bad
things happening to you you feel pain
anyways so why not feel the pain of
trying and failing rather than the pain
of apathy and despair and neglect this
doesn't mean spend all of your money on
the latest crypto thing and hope to get
rich because that's just dumb start off
small try to strike up a conversation
with the person in the elevator or the
grocery checkout you might risk being
perceived as sort of a weird person that
people don't want to talk to but that's
a great example of a risk that is kind
of worth taking because even if you are
seen as a weirdo and they literally go
ugh why are you talking to me that sort
of rejection when you voluntarily
subject yourself and you are aware that
that could happen but you do it anyways
that is an empowering rejection that's
the thing about risk when you are aware
of the negative downsides but you make a
calculated decision to go for it anyways
when that downside happens you at least
respect yourself for trying and as you
take more risks in life as you step
outside of your comfort zone you start
to get better at evaluating risk you
start to be a better judge of what could
go wildly wrong with very little upside
versus what has like pretty good upside
and very little downside you start to
develop resilience you start to develop
this like bounce back nature this
anti-fragility so it's never too late to
start taking more risks obviously don't
be dumb if you have a family don't Bank
everything on the stock market
especially right now don't quote me on
that it's just a hunch but like I said
from the start life is inherently risky
you know by not taking risks and not
getting comfortable with risks that's
risky in and of itself in fact it's
worse than risky because not only do you
risk not getting what you eventually
want in life you pretty much guarantee
it so if you're starting to feel sort of
apathetic in life stop sitting at the
shore living in fear for the next big
wave to get all of your clothes wet
learn to surf and expect to be bad at
the start art but you'll get better the
fourth thing that you can do to
dramatically improve your life is to get
out of your head assuming you followed
step one and you developed a Clear
Vision of what you want with your life
and the things that you typically want
to do each day then you've already done
plenty amount of thinking so often in
our lives we think that we need to think
things through in order to do something
but like for 99 of the things we really
do not like if you really feel like you
should be getting back into the gym
again and you start to feel inspired
because you watch this like I don't know
workout Montage transformation video
we're like oh yeah man I really should
start going to the gym again so you
start looking up new workout clothes to
buy you start spending money on this
like Advanced YouTuber fitness
influencer program you spend all your
money at GNC it's like you don't need to
do this much thinking just go to the
[ __ ] gym do the thing before you can
even think about it because as soon as
you start thinking you already know
you're an absolute Master at finding a
way to weasel out of it even if the
rationale is fairly cohesive the result
is that you didn't end up doing it so
many things in life are like this if you
need to write your final essay as soon
as you think about it and you already
know it's good for you you need to
become efficient at just putting one
foot in front of the other and already
start doing it like literally shut your
brain off and start thinking about the
essay when you've already written like
six words for it 99 of us have a problem
of overthinking not under thinking step
number five is produce always produce
more than you consume and in this highly
consumeristic culture that is very
challenging especially if you are like
most people nowadays including myself if
I'm not careful so many of us sort of
sit there living life passively you know
we're living life on our heels willingly
hypnotizing us with whatever content is
displayed for us when we enter in
YouTube you know maybe that's this video
maybe you've been incessantly watching
self-improvement content click away from
this video you don't need this video
like come back to it later go do the
thing that you're supposed to do you
know go Purdue stop consuming content
like this you know if it's the end of
the day and you know you're kicking back
and having a good time then maybe keep
on watching but I'm literally gonna
screw myself with this video algorithm
wise because I genuinely mean it go do
something more important you know life
feels so much more exciting when you are
creating more than you're consuming if
you like watching videos learn to make
them if you like scrolling Instagram
looking at photos learn to take them the
satisfaction that we're longing for when
we're doom scrolling is the feeling of
creation it's being in the Flow State
feeling like you are where you're
supposed to be and you're doing
something significant you're putting
something out into the world so always
try to produce at least as much as you
consume preferably more step number six
is to welcome feedback don't just
surround yourself with people who think
exactly who you think and you have like
three or four people that you talk to
and you all have the same opinions about
everything and you look with judgment on
people who live life differently because
your world is so small that's pretty
much everybody it's important to have an
inner circle absolutely and a lot of the
time your inner circle will think a lot
like you think absolutely but surround
yourself with people who challenge you
who want to hold you to a higher
standard if you start to stray off the
path they can bring you back onto it and
a lot of the time that won't be very
comfortable a lot of the time that'll be
a hit to the ego but you want to find
people who want the best for the best
version of you you know not just people
who want you to be comfortable all the
time try to reflect on the fact that you
probably don't know everything and there
there's a lot to learn from other people
this doesn't mean be spineless and not
stand up for what you think is right but
do it in a way that is solution oriented
not ego oriented you do not know
everything number seven is be vulnerable
now a lot of you might say that one
sounds pretty beta to be honest with you
that sounds Super Beta Joey's a beta
sure
by being vulnerable I don't mean expose
your vital organs to a dirty Bandit with
a sharp knife I mean don't be afraid to
be emotionally vulnerable emotionally
honest to your inner circle to the
people who are holding you to a higher
standard now what does this mean and
what's the utility of this well let's
look at the alternative the alternative
is to be secretive to have things that
you're ashamed of that you never tell
anybody you stuff it down you pretend it
doesn't exist and a lot of the time when
you have bad habits or addictions or
something like that and you keep them
hidden they tend to Blossom in the
shadows right they start to weigh on you
far more than they probably should when
you don't expose your flaws and your
darker side to anybody when you're not
emotionally vulnerable and honest you
know no one really knows who you are you
conceal a part of yourself from the
world reflect on your life are there
things that you do behind behind closed
doors that you wouldn't do if that door
were to swing open and Grandma was home
that was a very weird way to put it if
there are things that we do that we
don't want to admit to other people it's
important to find the courage to let
somebody know somebody that you trust
it's a very Christian idea actually
confession isn't for God or for the
priest or for a person that you're
confiding in it's for you it's to shed
light on the darker aspects of yourself
to sort of like heal it to like Purge it
in a way because these darker sides of
ourselves thrive in secrecy don't be
afraid to confide in somebody that you
trust about things that you're not so
proud of because a weight will come off
your shoulders every single time it's
like cathartic and you can live your
life with more freedom to sort of pursue
the higher version of yourself where do
you find these types of people outside
of your house thing number eight to
dramatically improve the rest of your
life uh this one's probably the hardest
one to do it's the one that I struggle
with the most and that is to embrace
conflict now this one might sound
interesting but the alternative is to
run from conflict if you have a problem
with something let somebody know right
otherwise you're an absolute doormat if
someone wrongs you you know does
something to hurt you does something out
of line that you don't appreciate don't
just be like oh that's okay because if
it's not okay it's not okay don't say
that it's okay because by doing that you
look weaker so that person is more
likely to take advantage of you in the
future and they say like wow this guy's
an absolute doormat but far worse is
that you don't respect yourself as much
you say like wow I just let people walk
all over me because I don't want to deal
with slight discomfort in the short term
is that something I struggle with
personally you know I'm a pretty
agreeable person a lot of the time I
want to make sure everyone's comfortable
and having a good time and you know I
have fairly thick skin I played hockey
and you know dressing room culture and
small town Canada you know people throw
Jabs and I don't think that like being
overly sensitive is particularly
beneficial in that circumstance you do
have to let stuff kind of bounce off a
little bit but when something crosses
the line you know it and a lot of the
time those aren't like little Jabs or
you know humor a lot of the time that's
just like straight up
disrespect they say something about a
family member of yours or at work
something genuinely unfair or
unprofessional or unsafe happens don't
just be like that's all right yeah like
don't worry about it yeah you have to
speak up right otherwise you don't have
a spine and if you've gotten in the
habit of doing this over years and years
and years you almost have to like
re-earn your spine again and that's
tough that's really tough it's something
that is extremely important because that
goes along with honesty speak the truth
if you don't like something say that you
don't like it be willing to risk people
perceiving you as mildly unpleasant in
the moment in order to gain respect not
just from the people around you but
respect for yourself when the elephant
in the room comes barging in talk about
the elephant be like hey look at that
elephant right there what are we gonna
do about it the thing's huge
don't have elephants in your room they
don't belong in your room they belong in
the zoo or in the wild actually if I say
they belong in the zoo I'll get canceled
they belong
foreign
elsewhere step number nine don't play
RuneScape I put that uh tip in the video
and it's like the number one comment is
like lamou I died at play RuneScape I
played a lot of RuneScape like a lot I
think I should change it in the video to
play RuneScape 3 because old school
RuneScape still slaps alright tip number
10 is be optimistic I think optimism
gets a bad rap because people will look
at optimism and they'll say man this
person is not based he doesn't realize
that there's a lot of suffering in the
world and it's not all sunshine and
rainbows but unless I have a different
definition of what optimism is optimism
is the opposite of pessimism pessimism
is where you look at any situation and
you find the negative in it you know the
glass is always half empty if you are a
pessimist you compulsively put a
negative spin on things you know you
have a habit of looking at anything good
or neutral or bad and finding the Fault
in all of it and while that might be
true because the fabric of our reality
is inherently tainted in a lot of ways
suffering is a part of life everyone's
aware of that but why would you add to
the suffering by being compulsively
negative by finding a way to complain or
lament about all these things you have
to do you're basically cutting yourself
off at the knees before you can get
going there's no shortage of suffering
in the world you know life is hard
people on motorbikes could ruin your
shot as you're trying to do a video at
11 PM when you have to wake up at 5am to
catch a flight to London oh life is so
hard I'm going to London if you have a
tendency to compulsively look for the
negative in everything you add to the
net suffering of your life it doesn't
improve your life to be overly negative
right seek to find the good in
everything rather than the negative
that's what being an optimist is all
about it's not being blind to the
negative aspects of the reality around
you it's choosing to focus on what's
good there's a reason why gratitude
journals have been shown to cure in a
lot of people clinical anxiety or
insomnia right there's some really
interesting studies on that and it's
because people focus on the positive
aspects of their lives and the things
that they're grateful for it doesn't
mean that they like created anything new
they're just remembering things
differently and they feel better about
their lives right they have a internal
peace that they're fostering because
they are able to habitually see the
positive aspect of things
and there's the motorcycle again I love
the motorcycle because it reminds me of
what an amazing job I have do I actually
think that I don't know but I feel good
rather than negative
and if you're really good at being a
pessimist it's really difficult to
actually recognize when you're doing it
because you do it so regularly and it's
such a intellectual sleight of hand that
it's really hard to pick up a lot of the
time this is a very difficult thing to
do to remain optimistic in times of
trial it's not easy but it is deeply
meaningful and is deeply satisfying to
try to be that person so try to
recognize all the little ways that you
are being negative about yourself being
negative about your capabilities about
your future about your past your present
try to find all the little ways that
you're spinning little fun little spider
webs into negativity I don't know how
that makes sense it doesn't but neither
does being negative so
if you've made it to the end of this
video try that today for the rest of the
day or make a note of it tomorrow be
extra mindful about the stories you tell
yourself about the world around you and
about your own life is this a hopeful
story or is this an overly Bleak and
negative story with no aim and no
encouragement the world isn't a very
encouraging place and the last person
that should be robbing you of
encouragement is yourself your life gets
better when you're optimistic I will die
on that Hill if you have been not
feeling so good you watched my last
video and it made things worse then
hopefully by listening to some of these
tips you are starting to get some ideas
as to how you can start feeling better
and again a lot of these things are just
scratching the surface maybe these
things weren't very practical or
Hands-On but hopefully they got your
mind working as to how to get out of
some of the negative thought patterns
that we find ourselves in so that you
can dramatically improve the remainder
of your life and as usual
thank you so much again to our wonderful
sponsor athletic greens so I just got
back from the UK where I was away for
two weeks with Jared and honestly we ate
very poorly I wouldn't call our meals
nutritionally spectacular so over the
course of the trip that really started
to weigh on us and both Jared and I
ended up getting sick so when we were
away we were like man why didn't we
bring those athletic greens travel packs
we probably would have felt so much
better so that's why I've been taking
ag1 for the past two years because I
actually really enjoy the taste and
there's basically no competing with its
nutritional profile it's packed with
over 75 vitamins minerals Whole Food
sourced superfoods and adaptogens in
every single scoop ag1 really makes sure
that you're giving your body everything
it needs to stay focused and energized
throughout the day and since it's
sourced from Whole Foods your body can
actually absorb it it has a high degree
of bioavailability so when you drink it
your body can actually deploy it and
various faculties so if you want to join
me in this simple daily habit that will
help give your body everything it needs
to feel fantastic and if you use my link
in the description below you'll also get
a year's supply of the vitamin D3 and K2
complex as well as five ag1 travel packs
with your first purchase so once again
click my link below to take advantage of
this offer and thank you again to
athletic greens for sponsoring this
video if you liked this video make sure
that you hit the like button because
when you actually move your mouse over
and click the like button the algorithm
goes okay this video is good and more
people should see it that is a huge help
if you hit the like button let me know
in the comments below which one of these
tips you most struggle with and which
ones you're most excited to work on I
would love to hear your side of things
other than that thank you so much for
watching as always and we'll catch you
in the next video
[Music]